Hi, I'm Michelle Klein, a member of the
GSB Alumni Association Board.
And I'm pleased to welcome you to this
production.
>> [FOREIGN]
>> Change lives.
>> Change organization.
>> [FOREIGN]
[FOREIGN]
>> Change the world.
[MUSIC]
>> Well, thank you for the awesome
introduction, I appreciate that.
I was super nervous.
And then you all started filing in and
then I was like, these
are all my great friends that I made over
the last two years.
And so I'm just so honored to be here.
And I am so grateful that you are
entrusting me with this last lecture.
It's just an incredible honor, it means
the world to me.
So thank you for that.
[COUGH] I want to say congratulations to
all of you, not
just on the last couple of years, but
really on
your whole lives, the 25 years or 30 years
leading
to getting to Stanford and everything you
put into it.
The incredible intensity, work, and
sacrifices you made, the
decisions you made, and the grit that you
showed to
get here, I hope you feel like you earned
the seat that you're sitting in and you
belong here.
And I just hope you'll over the next
couple of days appreciate
really what you've done because it's
really impressive, give yourselves a big
hand.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> The last lecture I took very seriously,
I said, this is my last lecture I'm ever
going to give, what am I going to say?
I'm going to try to tie in things we
talked about in class, things I talked
about
in wellness, and I'm going to talk about
even
stuff we did during lunches and stuff like
that.
I'm going to do all that in 25 minutes.
Let's see how it goes.
So I turned 50 this year, and as many of
you who know, who have had me
in class, I'm a pretty reflective person,
and I've
thought about what have I learned over
that time.
As Drake said, I've been on many journeys,
had lots of failures and some stuff go
well.
And what I realized at the end of all that
is that life is really the
most challenging journey of all that we're
all
going to have and that all of you will
have.
And then what I've realized over 50 years
is it's really an internal journey.
It's one that you're going to really be
wrestling with yourself over that time.
And there's a quote that I love that
summarizes this journey
better than anything I could come up with
from Michelangelo.
And Michelangelo sculpted the David and he
painted the Sistine Chapel.
And one of his early works was this angel.
People had never seen this intricacy and
detail in this angel before.
And they asked him, how did you sculpt
this angel out of this block of stone?
And Michelangelo said, famously, I saw the
angel in
the marble and I carved until I set it
free.
The reason that quote is so important and
that it's my favorite
quote is that we, all of us, we're the
angel in the marble.
And that we at our core are these
beautiful, infinite, incredible beings.
We have power beyond our wildest
imagination.
And we're perfect just as we are.
And that the real journey is to sculpt
away the stone that bring case in, and
most of the most constraining stone that
we have, actually, it's self directed.
It's the constraints we put on ourselves.
And it's things like, here's what my
parents think I should do.
Here's what my roommate's doing.
I compare myself to this person and I
compare myself unfavorably.
I can't do this.
I don't know how to do this.
I'm not sure I'm going to make it.
I might not work out, I might fail.
And I'm not ready.
I'm not enough.
And really, that's what's underneath a lot
of that, is I'm not enough.
So that's a stone that we kind of place on
ourselves.
There's a subtle part of this quote that I
want to
make sure that I make like not subtle,
which is
that Michelangelo's didn't sculpt the
angel or the David by
going out and finding a head and gluing it
on.
And then finding wings and then welding
those on.
The angel was already perfect.
And that really if I had a gift that I
could give to you, it would be
for you to just give yourself permission
to be
your true selves over the course of your
lives.
That would be the gift that I would give
you.
That's what I've learned over my 50 years,
is
that when you give yourself that gift, you
tap
into this energy source and this joy and
happiness
and really power that you can't access any
other way.
You can't access it by trying to be
someone else.
So what I'm going to do today is take you
on a little bit of a journey to,
hopefully,
help you unlock your potential, kind of
carve away
that marble over the next 25 minutes or
so.
And I'm going to use my own story to tell
you a little bit about this.
So I grew up in a small town in Ohio, and
actually, my
parents and my wife are here, who are from
that same town.
And-
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> I talk about my wife all the time in
class.
And she's actually not Snuffleupagus, she
is real and she's here.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And anyway, so I grew up in this small
town and I had a lot of marble around me.
I would have described myself as having
pretty average abilities, athletic
abilities, average intellect, really.
And I would say the town I was in was
average [LAUGH].
And that was my identity.
And so I had these pretty firm stone
walls.
And then when I was about 13, like a lot
of us,
I wanted to feel like I mattered, I wanted
to feel significant.
And so, in Ohio, one way to do that was
through athletics.
So I tried out for basketball and I got
cut,
and I tried out for football and I was too
small.
So we had wrestling in Ohio, that was one
of the sports we had.
And wrestling could be any weight class,
and they
didn't have cuts, so I was like, all
right, great.
My first three years, seventh and eighth
and ninth grade, really
the only way to describe my career would
have been forgettable.
And that, by the way, is a very optimistic
description of those three years.
So I got to ninth grade that summer, and I
said
two words that I've been saying my whole
life to that point.
I said, not me, not now.
No, I'm not the right person.
Now's not the right time.
I go on walks with some of you, and you'll
tell me about something
you're excited about and I'll hear you say
those words, not me, not now.
I'm not ready.
That summer, though, two things happened
for me.
One was, I bought a Sony Walkman.
And this was the 1980s version of your
iPhone.
And this was magical, just as magical as
the iPhone was.
And I was at the library one time,
checking out some music,
and there was this program and it said,
Think and Grow Rich.
I was like, awesome.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Who doesn't want to think and grow
rich?
Turns out that book wasn't at all about
thinking and growing rich,
it was about conquering your inner self,
that's what it's actually about.
It's a great book, Napoleon Hill.
But I became addicted to these self help,
for lack of a better word, audio tapes.
Listened to Zig Ziglar, Tony Robbins, Dale
Carnegie, Stephen Covey.
So I had a job over the summer, that
summer, every summer in Ohio, which is
mowing lawns.
I attach this Walkman and I put in Tony
Robbins, and then
mowing lawns is pretty straightforward,
you walk in a line, in the sun.
And then when you're done, you get to the
end
of the row, you turn around and you walk
back.
That's how pretty much I just taught you
how to mow a lawn.
And I did this for six hours a weekend for
my
entire high school ,and I brainwashed
myself with these tapes, basically.
And my parents had just gone through a
divorce, and And I wasn't
really part of a friend group, and
athletics wasn't really working out for
me.
So this became something for me to grab on
to, I was really impressionable.
And I grabbed on to these with everything
I had.
So I'll summarize, literally, I added up
the hours
one time and it's 1000s of hours I
listened to.
I'm going to summarize it for you in about
two minutes, you're welcome.
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] And the basic summary is that
about 99% of people never actually figure
out what they want.
There's a lot of activity, they spend all
this time.
They're running around, they're busy,
they're going all these directions.
But they actually never take the time to
figure out, what is it that they want?
And they said, you will be at the top 1%
if
you could just figure out what you want,
take that time.
We're going to talk about that today.
The best exercise that I know to figure
out what
you want, I've done with many of you in
class.
But I'm sorry I'm going to do it again,
because this is my last lecture.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Is imagine the following.
Imagine you rub a magic lamp, and a genie
comes out.
And the genie says to you, I can't give
you any wish.
But what I can give you is that whatever
you throw yourself into with your
life, whatever you really commit yourself
to,
that that is going to work out amazingly
well.
It's going to be way harder than you
think, it's going to take longer than you
think.
You're going to have [SOUND] some face
plants, it's going to be tough.
And when you fail, you're going to think
that I have abandoned you, but I haven't.
But it's going to be the journey of a
lifetime.
What would you wish for from that genie if
you
really had that power, if you really had
that blessing?
That's my favorite prompt that I've come
up with,
and I've shared that, obviously, with many
of you.
The second thing that happened that summer
was there was this movie called Vision
Quest.
How many of you seen Vision Quest?
Like two of you, awesome.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Actually and my wife, too, I've made
her see it many times, she raised her
hand.
Vision Quest [LAUGH] is, so for those of
you don't know, can't believe you haven't
seen it.
Vision Quest is a 1980s movie, it's kind
of like Rocky for wrestling.
That's the best way to describe it.
There's this wrestler named Louden Swain.
And he decides he's going to cut down two
weight classes,
and he's going to wrestle this defending
state champion Brian Shute.
And his buddy, kind of his friend that
goes on this journey with
him, says, Louden, you're on a vision
quest, this is a vision quest.
Well, this is a B movie, probably, by any
standard, except if you were a
15 year old wannabe wrestler from
Perrysburg,
Ohio, in which case it was my anthem.
And I still to this day, I've seen that
movie more than any other
movie I've ever seen, I can say pretty
much every line in the movie.
So anyway, those two things conspired, and
I
go back to wrestling my tenth grade year.
And I'm standing in the wrestling room,
and I'm looking up at the wall.
We're having a pizza party in the fall.
And I'm looking up at the wall, and
there's a list
of all the starting wrestlers, and I'm not
one of them.
And my buddy comes up, and he puts his arm
around me.
And he says, Weaver, only place you can
make
that weight, make the starting lineup, is
at 125 pounds.
And he punches me in the gut, literally
and figuratively punches me in the gut.
So to give you an idea, well, anyway, so I
look
at this, and I decide that I have a
decision to make.
And I'm eating this piece of pizza, and I
throw the pizza in this trash.
And I had this ceremonious moment where I
said,
all right, I'm going to go on my own
vision quest.
I'm going to drop to 125 pounds, make the
starting lineup.
Now this story is not end the way that
Vision Quest does.
I do make the weight, by the way, just
give you a sense of 125 pounds.
I was at the same height as I am now, I
weigh 185 right now.
So when I decided to cut the weight I was
150, and then another 25 pounds from that.
So it was, to this day, one of the hardest
things I've ever done.
But that moment when I threw the piece of
pizza in the
trash would turn out to be the turning
point in my life.
And the reason is that I basically drew a
line.
I didn't do this figuratively, but I did
this kind of in my head.
I drew this line here.
And this line, on this side of the line is
where I was.
And on the other side of the line are the
things that I
really wanted, the thing I wanted to be,
the goals that I had.
And up till that point in my life, I'd
always been tiptoeing
and putting my toe over on the other side
of the line.
But I really never believed it, I never
committed, I never stepped fully on the
other side.
And that was the first time in my life
where
I knew when I threw that piece of pizza
away, that
this wasn't going to be something I was
going to do for a
week, it wasn't something I was going to
do for a month.
This is something that I was committed and
I was going all
in and I did, and my mom can attest to
that [LAUGH].
So there are two things.
My story today, I'm going to share five
things with you,
five ways that you can free yourself from
the marble.
And I uncovered two of them that I'll
kind of highlight for you in that story.
The first one is that these walls that we
have around us, we view them as stone,
and they're the most dangerous when we
don't even realize that we have them.
And those are the stories we tell
ourselves, the assumptions we
make, the things that we say we can and
can't do.
The most constraining walls that you will
have are the
ones that you have made in your mind for
yourself.
Those are the ones that will cause you the
most problems.
And those walls are not actually made of
stone, but if you push them, they're
malleable.
And one way to push them hard is to
commit, to step over and not look back.
And then those walls will start to give,
and they'll
start to yield, and you can push, and
they'll move.
And so when I pushed on this wall, first,
I had a wall that was my athletic
ability, I have a wall of intelligence, my
wall
of who I fit in, my friends, all that.
But I started pushing on this athletic
wall, and it moved, and it gave.
And eventually I cleared it out
altogether, and had streaks, and I
became captain of a national championship
rowing team, having never rowed before.
And I realized there was no wall there at
all.
It was just walls I was erecting.
And the same was true with my view of my
identity for
intelligence, and many other things, is
that they weren't walls at all.
So my first takeaway is, almost any wall
that you can imagine will
yield to you with time, it will yield to
you when you're committed.
It will yield to you at your best, there's
almost no wall that won't yield.
Second takeaway I have has to do with your
identity.
We all act consistent with our identity.
So we're going to behave today based on
how we perceive ourselves.
What is our identity?
So where's your identity come from?
Well, your identity comes from your
subconscious mind.
And your subconscious, 95% of all the
things you think are in your subconscious
mind.
And so your subconscious is really
powerful.
Another thing I learned from these tapes,
95% is your subconscious mind.
And you've heard the expression, we only
use a fraction of our minds.
How many of you've heard that expression,
right?
We only use a little bit of it.
So I would say it differently.
I would say only a small fraction of our
mind is
working for us, and the other 95%, it's
all over the place.
And often, more often than not, it's
working against us.
So our identity comes from when our
subconscious is picking up cues all the
time.
It says like, you're not that good at
this, you're not that good at that.
You're not comparing well to this person.
Man, I failed at this.
I'm not as good as this, that's our
identity is coming.
So really our identity is coming from our
past.
What happened is, I started developing
these
genie goals, and having something I
actually wanted.
And one of the things these tapes would
say is
visualize it, write it down, talk about it
all the time.
In a very short period of time, my
identity started becoming my destination.
It'll happen like that.
So if you want to free yourself from the
marble, consider having
your identity be where you want to go, not
where you've been.
It'll completely change the way you look
at the world.
I want to go back to the movie, Vision
Quest, for a second.
So Vision Quest follows the arc of a very
common architecture of stories.
Joseph Campbell identified this arc, and
he called it the hero's journey.
So the hero's journey goes something like
this.
It says, once upon a time, there was a
hero and that hero felt something inside
of them.
They felt that they had this power that
they were ready to give to the world.
And yet, this hero lived in this ordinary
world
and they'd experienced the power at times,
but not fully.
They weren't really 100% able to express
this.
And then the story goes on and says, and
then
one day, until one day, something changed
for that hero.
They heard some call to adventure, some
call to action.
And the hero's reluctant at first.
They're not sure if they should answer
this call.
And I want to argue, this is where many of
you are right now.
Make no mistake, you are the hero.
You have this power inside of you that
you've felt that you know is there.
You've had this power that you've
expressed at times
in your life that is incredible and you
felt it.
And I know from teaching you, having
lunches, coffees,
dinners, drinks, I know that each of you
also is hearing a call.
The call could be that there's a problem
that breaks
your heart that you want to be a part of
the solution.
The call could be that there's something
you want to introduce
to the world of product and technology,
something like that.
The call, it could be something more
subtle.
The call is your call.
It's not what I think, it's not what your
neighbor
thinks, it's not what your roommate
thinks, it's what you think.
Your call could be that you want to be a
teacher, the call could
be you want to be an actor, or a writer,
or whatever it is.
Sometimes for some of you, it's really
loud,
that call, you know exactly what it is.
And for some of you, it's a whisper.
But you gotta listen to that call, you
gotta hear that.
And many of you are reluctant right now,
you're in the reluctant
hero part of the story, at least from
spending time with you.
I was the reluctant hero too when I
graduated.
If you were to ask me any time in the
two years I was at Stanford, what are you
going to
do, I said, I'm going to go build a firm
that's
going to unleash people and is going to be
built around talent.
That's what I said I was going to do.
And then when it came time to graduate, I
listened to
all my fears and my doubts and my limiting
beliefs, and
I kind of took this, I had this decision
to make
between these two jobs or doing what I
really wanted to do.
I made the decision the way a lot of you
make a decision, which is like this.
I made it in my head and I said, well,
here's a list of the pros,
and here's the list of the cons, and
here's the good things, and here's the bad
things.
I even had a spreadsheet of expected
value.
And this is the way I know you make
decisions because I
talked to you about it, and you all
kind of go like this.
And then I asked 37 different people for
advice,
thinking the 37th was going to have my
answer for me.
I'm usually the 37th on your list too, by
the way.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I made this decision.
And then, of course, with all this stuff,
I went to the well lit, well worn
path, because that seemed more logical and
more
straightforward, and that's where all that
analysis led me.
I went to a firm, and when I showed up,
honestly, a little bit of me died.
[LAUGH] And a little bit of me died each
day I was there, until.
So I kind of was that here looking out the
window, and I'm kind of
like waiting for someone to come rescue me
and take me on this journey.
But after a while, I stopped looking out
the window and I just became my
environment.
Their values became my values, their goals
became my goals.
Once again in my life, I had said, not me,
not now, not me, not now.
I had another catalyst come in the form of
sort of a
very tragic event, which is a close friend
of mine.
He woke up like all of us did today
thinking he had
his whole life in front of him, and that
was his last day.
And I realized that I don't know what I
was
putting off, I don't know when the time
was.
If it's not now, then when's it going to
be?
And I told myself at that time I was never
going to say the words not
me, not now again, and I don't know that I
have said it since then.
The third thing to think about in
unleashing yourself from the marble is
there's another
way to make a decision, which is not in
your head, but it's in your heart.
And there's a quote, which is, you can't
solve the problems of the mind with the
mind.
You can't solve your mind with your mind.
But you can, your answer is most likely in
your heart.
So the way to make that decision is to
really
silence your mind, and just think what's
true for you.
What's real?
Give yourself space, time.
What's meaningful for you?
What's the impact you want to have?
What would you do if you knew you weren't
going to fail?
And give yourself the space to think about
that.
And my guess is you already know
your answer, you're just not giving
yourself permission.
So the third thing is make your decisions
with
your heart and not your head, and give
yourself permission.
Nobody's coming to your rescue.
I thought I'd talk quickly about the
journey itself.
Some of you have started your journey,
some of you are going to start later.
Some of your journeys are completely
different
than my journey, but I'll tell you a
little bit about my journey because it's
going to have some things in common with
yours.
I started my firm, and it took me a year
to raise a fund.
We raised way less than I thought, it took
way longer
than I thought, but we got going, so we're
in business.
This was the first time I was going to buy
companies not using
credit card debt, but I actually had some
real money and investors.
I was excited, and then promptly lost
money on five of
my first eight deals, and lost money on my
first fund.
I had probably ten classmates invested in
my fund that lost them money.
I was embarrassed.
At my fifth reunion, I had a friend put
his arm around me and say, Graham, during
the greatest wealth creation of all time,
this was
the dotcom era, you're buying stupid label
printing companies.
[LAUGH] I remember thinking, yeah, that's
pretty much accurate.
[LAUGH] Not only am I buying stupid label
printing companies, it's not really going
that well.
So it wasn't good, but we started clawing
our way back and then
we got a little better, and then bam, we
got flattened by the recession.
I didn't raise a fund for three years, and
for
the second time, I drained my savings,
keeping payroll going.
So this is my inspiring entrepreneurship
story.
But the point of the story is that every
journey, using the hero's journey analogy,
think of Yoda in Star Wars or Princess
Bride, the journey ends up in the swamp.
You will end up in the swamp at some
point.
And the swamp is where you're mucking
around in the mud,
and you're not sure how to get out of the
swamp.
You don't know if you're going to get out
of the
swamp or when, and you feel like you have
failed.
This swamp feels like failure, is what it
feels like.
But, I want to just talk about failure for
one second.
I'm going to tell you that none of you
fear failure, and
you're going to be like, no, Graham, I
pretty much fear failure.
But you don't, what you fear is underneath
failure, which is you fear what happens
next.
You fear that you can't handle failure,
that whatever comes
after that, you're not going to be able to
handle it.
But then if you think back to your lives,
how many of you
have had something go really wrong that
you would have categorized as a failure?
Every single one of you, and you know what
happened?
You got up, you kept going, you're here,
and you're
about to graduate from Stanford Business
School [LAUGH] no less.
So, you can handle failure, every single
person
can handle failure and that's really what
you fear.
So in this swamp, this one quote is the
thing that kind
of helped me a lot is this quote by Vince
Lombardi who said.
He was the coach of the Green Bay Packers
and he said, the Green Bay Packers never
lost the
football game, but there were a couple of
cases
where we ran out of time, I love that
quote.
But the best thing about the swamp is
you're in control of the most
powerful part, the most powerful tool that
you need, which is you have the clock.
You're the one who gets to call the game,
and you don't have to call it until you're
winning.
So, my fourth takeaway is, the journey
you'll be on
will go through the swamp, and just
recognize that that's normal.
When you're in the swamp realize everyone
else has been in
the swamp too, realize failure is not
fatal, failure is not final.
You can handle failure, and ultimately you
control the clock.
As Winston Churchill says, if you're going
through
hell, keep going, [LAUGH] so that's my
four takeaway.
So, I'll summarize my takeaways and then
I'll leave you with one final thought.
First one is, the walls that are erected
around you, the most constraining
ones are the ones you put on yourself, and
that those walls will move.
Those walls are not a stone at all,
they're
very, very malleable, but they will move
if you
throw yourself in with commitment, and any
will almost
any wall will yield to you at your best.
Second is, consider your identity, you
will behave consistent with your identity.
So, start to think about your identity as
your destination not your past.
Third, make your decisions from your
heart, and 50
years I've never made a bad decision from
my heart.
Make your decisions from your heart and
not your head, nobody's coming to your
rescue.
No one's going to make that decision for
you, no one's going to
tell you it's time, no one's going to tell
you that ready.
You're the only one who can give yourself
permission, just you, but guess what?
You're the only one who needs to give you
permission too.
And remember, the journey will go through
the swamp, when you're in
the swamp, give me a call, I'll help you
out of the swamp.
But it's going to be normal and failure is
not
fatal, failure is not final, you control
the clock.
So, I'll just end with a story, my story's
about executive coach named Tom.
So, I'm in the middle of the swamp, waist
deep, this is right around the time of the
recession.
And I hire this coach named Tom, so here's
my introduction to Tom I'm going to
reenact it here.
I'm like, hey, Tom, I'm Graham, nice to
meet you, Tom gives me this blank look.
Like Graham I always say this, because
people Graham's kind of weird obviously,
Graham like Graham Cracker [LAUGH], so, I
just made it's a nervous thing.
This is Tom, Tom says, Graham, what if you
suddenly
realized you were put on this earth to do
something special?
So, Tom, right?
[LAUGH] So, good to meet you [LAUGH], Tom,
that was literally our introduction.
And then, we talked for two years and
every single
meeting we had, at some point, met
sometimes multiple points crale.
What if you suddenly realized you were put
on this earth to do something special?
And this one time we were at in San
Francisco, we're at the Deli and I'm
like, there's three people in front of us
and I'm on my phone, Tom's like, Graham
[LAUGH].
What if you suddenly realize you were put
on this earth to do something special?
So, I'll ask all of you, what if you
suddenly realized
you were put on this earth to do something
really special?
Think about that, and I want to draw a
line for you.
And you can do this tonight at home or you
can when you have some time, but there's a
line here.
And you're on this side of the line, on
this side of line it's really familiar.
You've been here before, you have these
thoughts from the past,
you have an identity, you're very
comfortable in this area, right here.
In this state of mind you probably have
some
walls, you're in your head, you're making
analytical decisions.
But there's a line, and over here is
really what
you want, on the other side, it's what you
really want.
You know that and only you would know that
and your heart knows that.
And over here is you realizing that the
hero's journey isn't just the
best architecture of a story, but it's the
architecture of your life.
It's the best story you could write with
this one life we got, and
you're the hero of that journey, you get
to be the hero of your story.
And over here, on the other side of this
line,
is this call to adventure, and you've been
called to.
If you really listen, and you really pay
attention, there's a call over here.
And finally on this side of the line, is
going back to what Michelangelo
said, that as you realizing that you
already have everything that you need.
And that you already are everything that
you need, and that you're enough, sure
enough.
Well, I finally realized, with Tom I would
go back and
forth thinking, is he a little crazy or is
he the Messiah?
Sometimes in the same conversation, and I
finally realized what he was saying.
He wasn't saying, Tom wasn't asking me if
I
was put on this earth to do something
special.
He was asking me, what would happen if I
realized that?
So class of 2022, what would happen if you
realized that you stepped over this line?
Thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
>> Thank you so much Graham.
>> Thank you so much Graham for that
wonderful last lecture.
We're going to move to Q&A, so, please
raise your
hands if you have a question you would
like to ask.
>> Chris, I'm a micron but I'll go first,
Zhan, can you hear me?
>> Yes.
>> Graham, thanks so much for that, I'm
always struck in this conversation and
hearing about you.
Talk about in class, and talking about
these
limiting beliefs which you talked about
here too.
Do you ever feel the tension between
convincing yourself that you
are enough but also keeping that drive to
do something special?
And how do you navigate that tension?
>> No, I have it all the time.
I mean, it seeps in, it's not like it just
goes away,
you have the doubts and fears and limiting
beliefs all the time.
And it's kind of what I said, which is I
try to think about what is
it that I want, what's the bigger why, and
what if I just lean into that?
And yeah, definitely sometimes I have to
remind myself
that I'm enough, it doesn't go away, those
voices.
There's a concept that people have used
calling our voices inside, our gremlin or
saboteurs.
And I remember thinking I was the only
person who had
this voice that was pounding me with all
this negative stuff.
And then I realized, my gosh, we all have
that.
[LAUGH] So I think, it doesn't go away,
but I think the awareness
that it's there is really the best thing
you can do to fight it.
>> Caroline has the next question.
>> Kevin.
>> I also go by Caroline.
Graham, thanks, appreciate the insights.
On one hand you talk about this sense of
urgency and
actively chasing what it is you think
you're called to do.
On this other hand, there's this notion of
delayed gratification, and spending time
either getting the credentials, or
garnering
the experiences before you chase that
thing.
Do you ever feel tension between those two
things?
And if so, how do you reconcile it?
>> Yeah, I don't know that there's a
conflict,
I think that there's a false dichotomy in
that, Kevin.
What I mean is, when you're clear on where
you want to
go, you should 100% accumulate things that
are going to take you there.
And if that is knowledge, if that's
experience, accumulate
things that are going to take you where
you want to go.
That's different than, this is where I
want to go, I'm not ready.
So instead, I'm going to kind of start on
this journey over here.
And they're very different.
So I think what you're describing is,
yeah, sure, if you're super clear on
your north star, anything you want to do
to move toward that is going to be
awesome.
But just be intellectually honest, if
you're really doing that, or
if you're just kind of moving tangential
to where you want to go.
>> Another question down here for Holly.
>> Thanks so much, Graham.
It was great to hear from you today and
I've loved being in your class,
and I take many of the things you've said
to heart and they've helped me.
I'm curious when you're, like genie goal
or the thing
you're going after, how do you balance
that with the
people in your family and in your life who
are
also going after their own things when you
have interdependent relationships?
>> Yeah, it's a great question.
I think just having a lot of communication
about what you're both going after
and then what you're talking about though
I think is more of a tactic.
I think you and Ben should [LAUGH] support
each other in trying
to achieve what you're both trying to
achieve and encourage each other.
And there might be times when you both
have to
take on roles that you're going to have to
share the duties.
But I don't think that that gets in the
way of
you both clearly kind of walking toward
what you're want to be going after.
>> I think Amanda, the next question.
>> Yes.
Hi, Graham, let's imagine for a minute
that the angel has been revealed.
You've self-actualized.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's very nice lighting up here.
I want to understand how you maintain
humility
and approachability when you reach that
goal, if
it is attainable, and to turn around and
be able to bring others up with you?
>> I think one of the things that,
I always thought was that, there's a
great quote by Marianne Williamson, I'm
not going to
get it right, but she basically says,
you giving yourself permission gives other
people permission.
You shining bright gives others permission
to shine bright.
And I think there's so much truth in that.
I mean, I think about the people that I
admire the most,
Whitney Wolfe Herd came to our class this
year, and she's just herself.
She just like, you can just feel her
energy in herself.
And from my mind, it doesn't have anything
to do with humility, it gave me permission
to
say, wow, this is what someone who's
really
fired up about what they want to do looks
like.
In terms of, I think people that you
perceive as arrogant are probably actually
not doing that.
[LAUGH] They're probably trying to pretend
and be something else.
The people that I know that I admire the
most, they actually are pretty humble
and they're pretty happy with who they
are, they're not trying to be something
different.
So I think sometimes arrogance is almost
the opposite of being your full self.
>> Jill?
>> Hey, Graham.
You've come such a long way from being
that
skinny kid, striving to make it on the
wrestling team.
>> Thank you.
>> And [LAUGH]-
>> [LAUGH].
>> My question is, during the-
>> No, you can just keep going [LAUGH],
ask your question.
>> My question is more, when you share
that story of friends coming
to you, they're kind of all involved in
tech, they're going with the bubble-
>> Right.
>> And you're buying a label printing
company.
>> Right.
>> At that point, how do you have
conviction to keep doing what
you're doing and not just follow the herd
and what everyone else is doing?
>> Yeah, it's a great question.
There is one person in my class who will
remain nameless, who follows every herd.
It was dotcom, then it was hedge funds.
And then, I think now he's doing a crypto
spark or something.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I'm actually not sure, I'm
exaggerating.
I think I'm exaggerating.
And [LAUGH] I think for me, at least,
I could see some progress, it wasn't all
bad.
There would be moments where I'd say, I
could kind of see how this might work out.
And I was having some small little wins
along
the way, which was enough to keep me
encouraged.
And the other thing is, I got really
fortunate that the very first three or
four people
we hired at Alpine were just unbelievable
partners of
mine, and they were in the swamp with me.
[LAUGH] And there's a good expression, I
don't know who said
it, which is like, a problem shared is a
problem halved.
And we were just in it together.
And there were days when I would have a
down day and I would need to get
dragged out, and there are days when they
would, and I would need to drag them out.
So that was a huge part.
So I'd say those two things is just having
some great people with
me and then just seeing a little bit of
progress along the way.
And also having the conviction to not have
to follow and dive into the herd.
I literally didn't understand a lot of it,
kind of,
won't go off on my crypto tangent, but I
don't understand.
I didn't understand a lot of that.
It wasn't like I'm smarter than everyone,
I actually thought maybe I'm
not as smart as everyone, but I stuck with
what I kind of understood.
>> We're down here to Mackenzie.
Thanks, Graham, I'm like right from the
center.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So, kind of getting on a little bit the
swamp point, I think looking back on
your career, it's easier to say, just
stick it out, stay in the swamp.
You're struggling, obviously it worked out
tremendously.
How do you know?
And we've heard a lot of stories from
people who've come to class of people who
have tried one thing, it didn't work out,
they left that on the side of the road.
They went and did something different or
they pivoted their company to something
else.
How do you know when the time is right to
just say, well, what advice do you give to
people to say, hey, this is not working
and
it's never going to and let me find
something else.
>> Well, and that's a great question.
There's a huge difference between pivoting
and
deciding you're done, there's a big
difference.
I mean we pivoted the whole time, we're
still pivoting.
I mean, I think that's really healthy to
say, hey,
this is working really great, let's do
more of that.
And this isn't working, let's do less of
that.
I mean, I think that that's just great
leadership.
I mean, that's what you're supposed to do.
What's different is, so often what I
see is like, imagine you're running a
marathon.
I see people run 25 miles and they don't
know
how close they are and they turn around
and run back.
[LAUGH] Which is 25 miles back when they
only had
to go one more season math, they just
finished the marathon.
So I think it's not about sticking with
something that's not working, I think it's
more
just having the confidence that you're
going to
figure out the answer with a few pivots.
One thing I'll just as an aside the thing,
the ones kind of question that we've asked
that
has made us more successful maybe than any
other
question is, what's working that we can do
more of?
Most people focus on what's wrong and
what's not going right.
But it kind of goes back to the angel
in the marble, which is like, there's
actually some
things that we're really great at that
we're true
to us that are things that make us
special.
Let's go all in on that.
So, for example, at Alpine, I would say
I'm an average investor.
I don't really have a ton of energy for
deals,
like that's not really what gets me fired
up, but
I'd say, the thing that gets me excited is
people,
and talent, and we build a whole firm
around that.
We leaned into what we're good at, so
I think giving yourself permission to do
that.
>> Kate.
>> Yeah.
Hi Graham, thank you so much for this
beautiful lecture.
My question is about reconciliation of
this call to action and
follow your path and your passion and your
cause and sacrifice.
When sometimes things happen and things
change drastically, it's
another call to respond to some inner
values too.
Maybe some traumatic experiences in your
family or something else.
How do you reconcile this, maybe time that
you take away from
your path, or energy, or anything else on
your journey?
>> Yeah, well, first off, I'm sorry
if that's what you're going through right
now.
And so I'm really sorry to hear that.
But what I'd say is what you're describing
actually is your call.
That's your louder call.
And you're actually doing, you're giving
that, you're listening to that
call, and that's the call that you should
be answering right now.
My call is, I'm not saying to anybody that
you should be an entrepreneur, you should
be a leader.
All I'm saying is you should listen to
whatever is true for
you, whatever in your heart you know what
the right thing is.
And it sounds for you right now, that
might be your
family, so I think that's exactly what you
should be doing.
And then when it's time, you'll decide if
you want to listen to another
call at that time, but it sounds like you
know the answer right now.
>> Karen.
>> Thank you, Graham.
You mentioned 99% of the people don't
figure out what they really want to do.
You and others at this school and in our
lives have been
supporting us on this journey to figure
out what we want to do.
Going forward, how can we continue to help
others in our
life that are maybe not in this room to
figure that out?
>> Yeah, well, the biggest thing you can
do and this is for all of
you or people you want to help is just
make make space to ask the questions.
Because, you have this crazy, all of you
when you get.
A couple months from now, I know this
is scary, you're going to actually be at
work.
And you might have back to back Zoom calls
for ten hours, it's really
easy just to get swept up in that, and you
need to make space.
You need to put two hours on the calendar,
and maybe you have a
coach, or maybe you have a couple friends,
you need to ask those questions.
And it doesn't always come out of the
first session or
the second one or the third one, it might
take weeks.
But you have to make space to listen
effectively.
And so the thing you could give to people
you're trying to help is space to ask
these questions.
>> I think our next question was back
here.
>> Good afternoon, Graham, thank you.
From someone who never made enough space
yet,
I'm very intrigued in your firm and
yourself and
how you encourage people and you focus on
people and help them uncover what they can
be.
What coaching do you give in terms of
balance between pursuing what you can be
identifying, consuming,
and committing to what you can be, and the
balance of whatever everything else in
life demands, right?
Do you see your team members struggling
with
that balance, and what advice do you give?
>> Yeah, and just to be clear, it's like
the bounce of just how
much they're throwing themselves into work
and
that they have other stuff that goes away.
One way to think about this is this is a
framework is that the
amount of work that you have is infinite
and you could fill
your entire life with it and you're never
going to be done.
That's also kind of depressing but the
reason I'm bringing it up is if you
say, I'm going to go to my son's football
game when I'm done with my work.
Or I'm going to make time to exercise as
soon as I'm done with work.
Or I'm going to go to my friend's wedding
when I'm done with work.
Like, just realize you're never done with
work, there is no
such thing for someone like you who's
driven and wants to go far.
And so you have to put those other things
in first, you have
to say, I'm going to go to the son's game,
or the wedding, or whatever.
And then the work is going to have to kind
of work around that.
because if you don't put those things in,
work will just consume everything.
Because you're never done, there's so much
that you can do at all times.
So for some reason that framework has
helped me a lot, not
ever feel like, I'm going to at some point
be done because you're not.
>> Melissa Parkinson.
>> Hey, Graham, I'm Melissa.
I was lucky to take your managerial skills
class way back in the fall last year.
And I'd love if you could re-share the top
mistakes you saw your
classmates make 20 years out because that
was something that really stayed with me.
>> Top mistakes my classmates made.
I mean I think I shared a.
Most of them in this talk, which kind of
gets swept up.
The two biggest, most dangerous words that
you or my classmates ever say are not now.
If you hear yourself saying those words,
just be really, really careful.
Be afraid because not now is really fear
kind of in another word or in another
format.
And it's very dangerous because, as I said
earlier, you become your environment.
The people you're with, their values
become yours.
And so mistake number one that I saw my
classmates make is
just putting it off and putting it off and
putting it off.
And then the other things would be things
I talked about in
the talk, which would be listening to your
head, not your heart.
And never really deciding what it is
you're excited about or what you want.
Those would be the probably the biggest
ones I've seen.
>> Great, we have time for one or two more
questions if there are any.
We have Kevin.
>> Hi Graham, Kevin here.
So you're a big fan of self development.
So I wonder what do you think about
improving on
your weakness or development area, and
working on your strengths.
>> Yeah, I'm a huge fan of working
on your strengths, because that's what's
uniquely you.
That's where your superpower is, is your
strength.
And what's interesting is, I always
remember thinking, well this is
my strength, I'm sure it's everyone else's
strength, and it's not.
The thing that you love, Naval Ravikant
always says, what's the thing
that for you is play that for everyone
else feels like work?
That's a good indication of where you
should be spending your energy.
because you'll always be better at that
than
anyone else, because you'll just do it for
fun.
For me that's teaching, I mean, my wife
can tell you that.
I'm walking around in my house, working on
lectures, and giving this
talk that I just gave to my pillows in the
living room.
And because that's play for me, that's
fun.
And so I think leaning into your things
that really give you energy is your
superpower.
There will be weaknesses that could
completely take you out of the game.
Usually that has to do with self awareness
and how
you're showing up and some kind of hard
edges you have.
That's usually the weakness that takes
people out of the game.
It's not usually intellect or horsepower,
its
ability to get along with people, really.
And so that's one that you probably need
to work on that enough
that you're not going to like shoot
yourself
in the foot playing to your strengths.
And that's the one that trips probably the
most people up that I've seen.
>> And our last question back here.
>> Hi Graham, I was incredibly grateful to
be one of your TAs earlier this year.
And I saw firsthand your commitment to DE
and I, diversity, equity and inclusion.
And all of the things that you do to
bring other voices into the room or other
opinions into
the room for people that don't look like
you,
sound like you, or have the same
experience as you.
And I'm thinking more about Karen's
question of how can we support other
people and whatnot who are not necessarily
involved in the same circles as us?
And I was just wondering could you say a
word about what you do to
learn or continue to hear from people who
don't look like you, sound like you?
And then what we could do to incorporate
that into how we
are showing up to boardrooms, meeting
rooms, pitches, whatever it might be.
So it's really a question about learning
from diverse voices.
>> Yeah, that's an awesome question.
By the way, thanks for the kind words,
Connor.
I mean, I'll tell you just an example that
we've learned over the years.
And I'll use it as an example of
companies.
Rather than talk in generalities, I'll use
a real example.
So when we go into a business, last year
we bought 127 businesses last year.
And when we go in, most often we are
actually putting in a new
leadership team, because that's what the
business
needs and we're very upfront about that.
The first move we make is to actually
enroll everyone in the company in where
we're going.
We have this expression that the answer's
always in the room.
We don't have the answer, there's no top
down.
It is literally enrolling everybody in
this in this conversation.
And I remember when I took over a
business, around 2010 I became CEO.
And I did this, I went on a listening tour
and I sat there with a yellow pad and a
pen.
And I went and met with most of the
leaders in the company,
and a lot of the people that were on the
ground as well.
And I sat down and the most common thing
that they
ever said was, no one's ever asked me my
opinion before.
[LAUGH] And the ideas were there, I didn't
have to
be brilliant, I just had to give those
voices oxygen.
And not only did I get a better
answer from that, but everybody felt like
they contributed.
And that they were enrolled in the
solution because they
had been asked and they'd been invited to
that conversation.
So you really just have to listen and you
don't have to be brilliant.
The people that you're going to lead, the
people that
you're going to be involved with, they
will have the answer.
And you just have to kind of make sure
you're giving their voices some oxygen.